we got this company just about ready to
launch
and uh we're looking at it when looking
at this little tiny fulfillment center
we were here by then in this building we
had a basement fulfillment center to
call it a fulfillment center was very
grand there's a lot of puffery it was
400 square feet
which is about the size of a one car
garage
and we launched this uh business and
we're looking at it and we didn't know
if anybody would order from us we really
didn't and in fact one of the software
engineers looked at this little space
and he said i can't figure out whether
this is
incredibly optimistic or hopelessly
pathetic
um and indeed we didn't know we had no
idea whether anybody would want to buy
things in this way the business plan
called for
generating sales very slowly as
customers change their attitudes the
original business plan which i thought
was very optimistic at the time called
for amazon.com to generate 70 million
dollars in sales in the year 2001.
we actually generated an excess of 3
billion dollars in sales in the year
2001
and we knew by the way that we were
really onto something in those first 30
days in the first 30 days
we got
orders from all 50 states and 45
different countries with not a dollar of
advertising just all word of mouth in
the first year we didn't spend anything
on advertising all of it was word of
mouth and that really forged the company
as a that we were going to focus on
customer experience because we saw the
power of word of mouth so so very very
clearly in those early days there's
something great about
word of mouth online by the way and
feedback from customers which is that
email turns off the politeness gene in
the human being it's wonderful so people
actually tell you what they really think
usually in all caps
and uh
so
we get lots of info and feedback from
our customers and we try to try to use
it well wanna be happy build a life not
just a business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get the seven
best lessons from jeff bezos elon musk
and other highly successful
entrepreneurs
enjoy
lesson number two make many mistakes
with elon musk it's hard to say because
things have worked out pretty well in
the end so how how big of a mistake
could it have been as the question is
really really asking um
you know i did lots of dumb things at my
first company and at paypal
and
you know i think i think sometimes
yeah i don't know there's so many i like
i'm hard pressed to say this is this is
the biggest one you know
give us one or two
okay um
okay sure
so
there
the the biggest mistake in general that
i've made and trying to correct for that
is
uh
to
put too much
of a waiting on somebody's talent and
not enough on their personality
and i've made that mistake several times
in fact
i don't say oh gee i'm not going to make
that mistake again then i would make it
a game
and and i think it actually matters
uh whether somebody has a good heart
it really does and i've made the mistake
of thinking that sometimes it's just
about the brain lesson number three
prepare with warren buffett i think
you'll learn more about yourself
uh if you do it that way i bought my
first stock when i was 11 i was actually
i was at rose hill at the time and i
bought three shares of city service
preferred
at uh 38 and it went down to 27 which is
something i still remember even though i
was 11 at the time
and then it went up to 40 and i sold it
i made five bucks on my three shares
after commissions and then it went to
200 and something so
uh you know i i probably remember that a
little better than if i'd been doing it
on paper you know
and
i fooled around doing a lot of things
between about age 11 and 19 in the stock
market i did charts i did all kinds of
technical analysis i read every book i
could get on the subject
and
i didn't do that well i didn't do
terrible but but i did i was really just
floundering around but by
that meant by the age of 19 when i read
ben graham's book i was at the
university of nebraska in lincoln i went
and bought this book called the
intelligent investor just come out and
it had an enormous impact on me
now if i hadn't done
in the previous eight years if i hadn't
been all over the lot i'm not so sure
that that book would have had the same
impact on me i mean i was by that time i
was prepared
to read ben graham's book which changed
my life financially in an
incredible way i mean
i wouldn't be up here today if i hadn't
read that book but
yeah part of life is getting prepared
so that
when something does happen that's
significant you can grasp the
significance of it and know what to do
with it and i would say that first eight
years of fooling around
even though it produced nothing
financially to speak of
uh produced a lot in terms of getting my
mind prepared for when i really did read
something that made sense so i was ready
to accept it and i actually went back
and
went to columbia to study under the
under graham and
uh
because of
of reading that book and all kinds of
things flowed out of it also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four be graceful
with oprah winfrey dr king said not
everybody can be famous
and i don't know if everybody everybody
today
seems to want to be famous but fame is a
trip
people follow you to the bathroom
listen to your pee let's just
try to pee quietly it doesn't matter
they come out and
say oh my god it's you you peed
[Applause]
that's the fame trip so i don't know if
you want that
so
dr king said not everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service
yet those of you who are history
scholars may know the rest of that
passage he said
you don't have to have a college degree
to serve
you don't have to make your subject and
verb agree to serve you don't have to
know about plato or aristotle to serve
you don't have to know einstein's theory
of relativity to serve you don't have to
know the second theory of thermodynamics
and physics to serve
you only need a heart full of grace and
a soul generated by love lesson number
five keep the worry with tillman
fertitta i know there's a paddle for
everybody's ass and and i talk about it
in the book and and i think that's
probably
you know
what i could give everybody out there
who's ever made a few dollars
uh you better watch for even today you
know when i came out yesterday was
number 140 on the forbes list 4.9
billion i still get up every day and
worry and worry if that paddle is gonna
get my ass okay and the day you stop
worrying and you just spin freely the
paddle's going to get you because you
don't know what's going to happen is our
government going to change to a
socialist government is is all of a
sudden somebody's going to come out and
the millennials say we're never going to
eat meat again right right
you know you just don't know but but but
we've seen some crazy things happen in
our world and during my lifetime
and and uh
in your lifetime already so so so
remember i mean i'm the one who grew up
and and you had one telephone and in the
house and and if you wanted to talk to
your friends you went to that telephone
and and it was just a different world
it's just a different world lesson
number six be relentless with mark cuban
i'm relentless i mean
i'm the guy i mean
i remember my first company micro
solutions
i'd buy a bucket of ribs
and we we did the system integration and
i wrote software i'd buy a bucket of
ribs and ribs i would just eat as i
would software as i would write software
and i'd be there and all of a sudden be
36 hours later you know um or i'd lose
track of days just because i just get so
focused and so involved in it um that
that's what i do and and and you know i
still you know i i read the haddock
manual and learned a little bit about
pig latin and i just want to keep up
right and so that that's probably my
biggest strength and lesson number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is find good role models
with grant cardone my dad died when i
was 10 years old i had an older brother
die when i was 20. by the time i was 21
years old i was jaded
and just figured hey life is not going
to last very long
and so somewhere
from when before my dad died to 21 years
old in between there i i thought i was
going to be a businessman one day i
thought i was going to be rich and
successful
and james bond
like i had all these ideas like when
you're a kid you have all these big
giant ideas and then life starts
lost
dad lost brother
girlfriend lose her like i start
accumulating all these losses
start using drugs and alcohol
start using them every day
start making bad choices
25 years old i was broke
i was in debt
couldn't keep a relationship
had no no chance of being married or
having kids it was impossible
right it was just
none of that was even possible
and and and
so so i started putting my life back
together but it's really
to throughout the period from 25 to
today 35 years now of me studying people
that are successful that has given me
the discipline
and the encouragement
along the way with some milestones like
2008 when the economy collapsed that was
a
that was a huge awakening for me
uh getting married
another monster awakening like it gave
me another reason to be have a purpose
being a good role model for my kids not
just talking the talk
but being someone my kids could look up
to and said that
that's what success looks like
just having money
just having
a couple million dollars
if you're not making a difference that's
that that's one level of success but for
kids they don't care how much money you
have
my kids don't
they they don't know that well what what
a
what does 167 million in cash look like
in an account i remember when a
billionaire showed me his cash account i
was like whoa
400 million dollars sitting in one
account i'm like my god i i literally
couldn't read the numbers my kids don't
even care
what my kids do care about what changes
children and what changes friends and
what changes your neighbor
is what they see you doing every day
and it just so happens it takes money to
do things
to fly across the world to make new
friends to create new charities yeah you
know to market to advertise etc
people are like oh bigger is not better
and you know i'm better off by myself
you are not better off by yourself it is
absolutely impossible to live on planet
earth as one person
try to communicate the seven billion and
think you're going to stay in the game
you're not it's impossible so you
solopreneurs out there
your business model that you created is
already broken thinking i'm going to be
by myself and do it by myself
and the proof is in the pudding because
there's 28 million small businesses in
america 22 million of them uh break even
or lose money those 22 million all have
one thing in common
no employees no support i made the
mistake in my life of studying people
that
appeared to be successful
a lot of people are like that
they appeared to be successful you know
today today in the the the the times
that we live in you know you can go on
instagram it looks like
looks like everybody owns a ferrari
everybody has a rolls royce everybody
looks like they're having the best day
of their life that's not studying that's
watching
i want to study people
or even even at conferences you can go
to a conference and watch somebody on
stage and he couldn't he he or she could
present to like they're so successful
but
if you really get behind the scenes
you'll find out there is no success
there it's just a lot of talking
and so i would just strongly suggest to
people to
pick
a handful of people and make sure those
people are actually doing
not just
saying
you know that they're they're not
talking about success they're actually
doing success every day and how would
you know what they're doing
well you should you would you would see
it in their statistics right like
there's some things you can't fake yeah
you can't fake somebody
uh we're buying 250 million dollars
worth of real estate this month
with my money
hard to fake that okay it's a great
instagram post by the way but you can't
fake it
there's going to be a loan there's going
to be a building there's going to be you
know acres and acres of land there's
going to be people living there like you
just can't fake it so there's a lot of
things you can fake you know you can
make a nice little quote put it on
instagram
people look at it like that's the truth
you know and and uh
the public is is
confused with a lot of what appears to
be the truth that's not
and so i would just tell people
um
study people
that have success that are doing it now
also the second thing i would say is
make sure that where you're getting your
advice from them
lines up with where you need advice
right so warren buffett you know warren
buffett he he's at the he's at the he's
at the tail
um he he's at the tail of his of his
he's probably here right
so
here he was doing different things than
he's doing here he he talks about
investing in stocks but he actually
doesn't do it he doesn't buy stocks he
buys companies yeah
so you got to you got to listen to
people steve jobs right here was one of
the most aggressive
business people that this plan has ever
seen i mean he was barbarian aggressive
so was bill gates but if you talk to
bill gates today bill and steve steve's
not alive obviously but
bill gates today saying dude i'm giving
all my money away money doesn't matter
that's not what he was saying right here
like right now in 2020 here we are in
april right we have this covida thing
happen and we have massive unemployment
worldwide literally a worldwide
recession if not a depression about it
in formation right now
this is not the time for me to go try
something new
this is the time for me to double down
on what's working how to help people
right now how do i scale cardone
university how do i help customers i
need to actually contract a second
so that i could pull the forces back
and
prepare for another assault
yeah you can't just go run out like a
lot of people think 10x is oh all the
time you're 10x sometimes 10x means i
got to contract again get rid of some
stuff so i can double down or 10x on the
things that are working so i can move
again and set up that other company that
i want uh to
for instance the real estate i can't go
expand my real estate portfolio in this
environment today
not because i don't want to but because
the markets have seized up
i need a second
i need a second for things to relieve
themselves
uh to
to in order to go back and go from 7 000
units to 14 000 units
property's been a big part of your
career in investing in property
what you know can you just give us an
insight into do you still think that
that's a good investment for people
because i know you've been on record as
saying you know it's not a good idea to
to own your own house that kind of thing
what where you know what what are your
views on the current property market so
so the issue the issue for property
again i love real estate you know we buy
real estate every day every day i'm
trying to buy some real estate
but the problem is priorities people
guy gets out of school
gets married husband and wife oh we got
to buy a house that is the wrong first
thing to do like why are you buying a
house
we need a place to live that's an
investment a house is not an investment
a business is an investment
going to dinner with a client that is an
investment
going on a trip to meet with other great
people that could become investors or
customers that's an investment buying a
house a place to live
and the banks the banks years ago the
banks convinced the public that
uh a house is an investment a house is
not an investment
so why aren't people notice how many of
your friends bought a house but they
have invested money in their in their in
their business
they bought a house but they didn't
invest money in making themselves done
dude i am the house
it's the grant cardone house
okay where i live does it really matter
to me it could be the rich hotel it
could be the four seasons it could be
the marriott
it could be your house i could go bunk
up at your place
the investments people should be making
is number one in myself number two is in
my business and the third thing they
should buy once they got the first two
handled
everybody should start trying to invest
in real assets or real estate that pays
them i'm not talking about a house i'm
talking about
buy
buy a piece of real estate that other
people rent
from you
so that you get cash flow how do you
build a business with a strong base of
operations you talk a lot about sales
and marketing
but how
how do we do it that that sales and
marketing go into a strong base of
operations and process
how do you go
what advice would you give an
entrepreneur to build that strong you
need a strong culture you have to have a
strong culture and the culture starts
with the leadership right so
if
i'm trying to teach and this is what
happens in big companies
and causes big companies to fail us the
ceo often is not really connected to
what's happening on the ground
and um it's one of the reasons we've
been so successful in america
crowdfunding yes against conglomerates
culture is the leadership calls out the
people around him it keeps everybody
sharp exactly or you have a culture
where everybody's asleep exactly
you have culture either way it's like
what culture do you want you want
warriors and fighters and acquirers and
people that are hungry and never
satisfied or do you have a
a culture
we just left the meeting and they're
like we got problems here
people are satisfied
or
and not working hard enough there's a
handful of people that are extremely
aggressive here but for the most part
the the woman told me most people are
just making excuses not going to the
next level not taking the action
saying this or that about this or that
that's the reason why this or that is
this this or that right and and so you
got to build a culture of no excuses
means you got to bring hire people and
get rid of people
we met with some real estate agents
yesterday they hired a thousand sales
people
for this project they're doing 10 10 10
billion dollars worth of real estate to
sell
they want me to sell it all
i said yeah i can do that
so i'm sorry and and um
a thousand salespeople and now they're
down to a couple hundred i said dude you
don't call you you you you have to get a
strong culture
he's like we don't have any culture i
said oh yeah you do
you you on board people and then you
don't train them and educate them and
they make sure that they're excited and
keep with them you can't go to an event
for three days get excited and think
it's gonna last three weeks later it's
not
that's got to be instilled into the
culture
you know you look around these buildings
the way these buildings there's
reinforced steel there's concrete
there's glass there's blue like some
something's holding that thing together
the birds where i'm staying it's holding
it together
long after it's built and that's what
has to happen with management and
ownership well you know i managed to get
here steven and i have
absolutely uh differing philosophies
because he um teaches
um the idea of he has a book called um
not yeah what is a book called
the book is called you can make it
happen nine steps to success and he's
always um talking to me about cr having
a vision that would with no vision that
people perish and i always say i don't
have a vision i don't have a vision to
get here to where i am my vision was uh
surrendering to what i believe was god's
vision for me and i always say god can
dream a bigger dream for you that you
can dream for yourself i now believe
that i need a vision i think steadman is
finally right that uh in order to
continue to move forward that i need to
develop a vision for myself and um
one of my big goals is to use this
television show as a forum
and a catalyst for change in people's
lives that's one of them the other is to
move out into the world in a more um
uh
impactful global format
to help women and children across the
globe without education the people
perish without education
nobody will be able to survive without
education women cannot overcome poverty
will not be able to learn to take care
of themselves will not be able to move
forward on the planet so i want to use
my life and this television show to
continue to do that you find that behind
the facade of all of your opinions and
your beliefs that at the heart of us we
all
want the same thing i want the same
thing that you want and i know that
whether you are republican or democrat
or libertarian or whatever you call
yourself that underneath every body is
this desire need to be valued and to
know that what you say what you think
what you want to do in the world your
fullest expression of yourself that that
thing matters do you think there's a
proven formula that if a brand rookie
guy he's got a lot of ambitious gun out
of his but not a lot of knowledge on how
to do you think if he follows a formula
he's guaranteed to make it as an
entrepreneur no no okay so you don't
believe there's a guarantee to make it
no because who knows who you're going to
be competing with so if you put two two
people both following the same formula
both in the same industry right which
one wins you know maybe they both can
win and both be successful but you know
so i don't i don't think there's a
default default template for success but
i think there's things that you can do
to put yourself in the best position to
succeed you know so i talk about stuff
in the book you know i talk about the
one thing in business you can control
his effort
you know um going out there and sales
curing all you know so i i think you
know and i agree with your point that
there are things that if you do them you
put yourself in the best position to
succeed
but you know if you just walk into a
buzz you know a buzzsaw and somebody
else is doing a little bit better
you know what happens you know
there's there's no we live in a day and
age where you can start anything do
anything and
you you shouldn't put limits on yourself
i think everybody's here because they
don't believe there are limits on
themselves and that they can get out
there and do anything and i like to
point to myself look if i can do it
there's a lot more people out there that
can do it and you guys should never let
anything hold you back you have lived
your life as an iconoclast and in a way
that's a template for other people but
in a way it isn't so in other words how
much
you got an ordinary person ordinary man
or woman how much of an iconoclast could
you or should you be like mark cuban oh
i don't care just you should just be
yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody
thought or said i was just going to be
myself and you know on my dad's son on
my mom's son my brother's brother
you know um alexis alyssa and jake's
father tiffany's husband
this you know i just try to do the best
like everybody else i mean i've been
blessed
you know like i say all the time i'm the
luckiest guy in the world and i just try
not to take it for granted i try to
enjoy every minute and i think now as
i've gotten a little bit older i try to
give a little bit more back than i have
before and and try to help more people
and
i you know in terms of whatever if
anybody else finds himself in my
position just enjoy the moment enjoy
every minion of it i mean i guess my
question is are you a role model for
people in society
i don't know i mean
i never thought of it i mean it's not
something i try to be i just try to be
myself
you know i just try to to to help where
i can do what i can
um be a good dad
and you know
i i'm not trying to be something for
somebody else just myself growing up my
dad used to encourage my brother and me
to fail
so at the dinner table he would actually
ask us what did you fail at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go and high-five me
and
what it was such a gift what he was
doing i didn't realize that at the time
but he was redefining failure for me and
so failure became not about the outcome
but about
not trying
and
so you know the fear of failure as we
all know as entrepreneurs is one of the
greatest fears in life it's one of the
things that stops us in our tracks and
keeps us from trying something
and so i you know i incorporate that in
my philosophy at spanx we have we
celebrate failures we talk about them we
have oops meetings where i'll announce
the oops that i have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach
theme songs to our oops
and we'll play them in front of the
whole company but i think it's just so
important to to try to get the people
that you work with to take risks and to
be entrepreneurial and not live in a
place of i want to protect my job and
feel like i'm not safe if i make
mistakes what are you most grateful for
in your life recently
my children
that's easy yeah my four children i
think every mom has to say that right or
it's just i mean it's true it's really
how i feel
i'm also really grateful for being a
woman born in the right country at the
right time i had nothing to do with that
and i'm very grateful
and i wake up all the time thinking of
that you know my mom
we're only 21 difference in age 21 years
my mom her choices were so much more
limited and what was expected of her or
what her opportunities were so i mean if
you think about how long we've been on
the planet some people think a couple
thousand years some people think a
couple million anyway it's a long time
and by just 20 years in the right
country
i feel like i was born and had the
opportunity for spanx yeah you know to
fulfill a potential or something inside
of me as a woman that was in me
and so i'm grateful for that that's
amazing we live in a world where we
almost lose control of all of our time
every day we have arrows that i call
them arrows that come at us hey jesse
can you spend 15 minutes with this guy
he wants to pick your brain on
coconut water and hey can you pay this
guy this guy wants to borrow 50 and this
email needs to be like constantly
dodging all this stuff and we feel
obligated to say yes because we don't
want to feel you know let anyone down
and we lose control of our time how
could you be productive have a vibrant
life be successful if someone else
controls all your time or you're filled
with clutter so i did a very simple
thing
we can all do it i drew a pie chart okay
i said there's 24 hours in the day
i sleep seven of them
that leaves 17 hours in the day
i take three of them for me
and those three hours could do anything
that i want i could be i'm going for a
run a steam i'm doing nothing i'm doing
my emails i'm reading but i don't want
to resent my wife i don't want to resent
my boss i don't resent my partner for
taking away the things in my life that i
love to do by controlling my time three
hours for me the average american works
a 40 hour work week that's eight hours a
day seven for sleep three for yourself
eight for work guess what
you got six hours left in the day all
the clutter's gone now of course you
have to commute you have dinner you have
family you have meals the point is
you can be incredibly productive
incredibly creative and credibly free
when you take control of your time when
you figure out how you want to attack
your time over the course
of a week i thought a monastery would
just be all prayer reflection meditation
and a meal a day or something
but a huge part of it is manual labor
because they have to keep the lights on
and the monastery that i went to
uh which was not it was not buddhist it
was russian orthodox they were the
largest breeders of german shepherds in
this country and i remember the first
day i was my job the first day was to be
a distractor so they were training one
of the dogs and i had to like run in
front of the dog and you know try to
like get him off of his game to simulate
traffic in the city or distractions
and the goal is to have the dog be able
to walk
unblemished no matter what you throw at
him and i was going crazy i was running
at him i was like you know doing the far
trick all that stuff and um the dog
didn't
waver it just walked from point a to
point b
and
one of the monks that was training the
dog said to me it's no different than
life you know it's like giving me all
this like you know uh wax on waxed off
[ __ ] but he was saying you know you're
gonna get distracted from your goals
and all these things are arrows are
gonna come at you all the time
but the same way this dog goes from
point a to point b even if there's a
pork chop there
whatever your goal is you got to get the
po you have to get there even though
people are going to say you can't do it
even though people are going to throw
different opportunities you know you
know i'm sure your friends went out a
million times to happy hour when you
were to stay late when you were starting
your business i mean i was in the same
situation
those are the distractions that come at
you but to get to your goal you can't go
to happy hour every night you have to
return emails and you have to check the
manufacturer and you have to
check the inventory and you have to make
sales calls how in your life have you
stayed the course how have you stayed
focused when
you had and maybe this goes to your why
you know what was it that allowed you to
keep going when your friends were going
out to happy hour
well i think like everybody i feel
overwhelmed a lot still
even though i'm older now and i've had
some success and failure but i still
have a lot of arrows that come at me uh
all the time requests for my time
challenges at work challenges raising
kids
being in a marriage you know is not easy
i mean we have a great marriage but it's
not east work sure um and it's
overwhelming so for me i think part of
it is always having something
big on my calendar that i can look
forward to
uh every every other month
i try to put something on my calendar
for a weekend that i can really look
forward to so it helps me get through
the tough times and i like to have one
at least one really big challenge a year
that kind of centers me and and keeps me
honest
keeps me honest and
that's really helpful for me and then
the other thing that i do that really
helps is i have a journal and i just
take everything that's on my head
and i keep it in a master journal
doesn't mean i'm going to get to it
doesn't mean it goes away but it gets
out of my head and it goes somewhere
else to free up
space in my head
and then i'll just work it off or i'll
prioritize it from the master list but
just the act of taking all the stuff
that's in your head putting it on paper
in one place where it lives
is like
really freeing and energizing now why
why the point of having a seal live with
you this is this book's called living
with a seal 31 days training with the
toughest man on the planet and i watched
a few videos on this guy he's a freak um
but why did you decide to
to have him live with you when he first
moved in the first he comes into the
house and he has a little knapsack for
30 days if i go away for 30 days i'm
checking two bags he has this little
like huck fin for 30 days with all his
clothes and everything and his whole
life in the bag and i said to him his
name is david goggins so if you're
listening and you know him or you want
to google him i said in the book i
referred to him as seal but now you know
he's out there so
he came to the house and i said to him
you know hey
here's your room you know i'll show you
around make yourself at home and you
know my home is your home for the next
30 days and he said no no he said i
don't have a home
and i said no make yourself at home it's
an expression
and he said
i don't operate in expressions wow and
that was sort of like okay let's start
so that was that was kind of our opening
act no settling in no
yeah and then we went down to the uh gym
five minutes into the into our 31 day
journey
and um
he said i want to see how many pull-ups
you can do so i said all right so uh i
guess to kind of get a level of like
where i was at and i am not a strong
sure guy so i did maybe eight pull-ups
and then i dropped down and said all
right wait 30 seconds and do it again do
it again so i waited 30 seconds got back
up on the bar i did like six he said all
right one more time and now like i'm
starting to feel it you know like i i
don't think i can even get back up on
the bar and i get i get three but three
like you know kicking getting my chin
over like whatever i could do to get
over the bar
so i said all right what's next he said
what's next is we're gonna stay here
until you do 100 more
oh my gosh and i said you're doing one
at a time
and i'm like come on man like that's
great on paper
but i physically can't
do
100 more
and
that was our start of many lessons that
i learned because i ended up doing it
one at a time
and what he taught me was that so many
of our limitations are self-imposed
you know and we set we set something up
in our brain we program our brain one
way
and that's our limit
and until we can get past that and see
what we're really made of and like get
uncomfortable and experience pain
you can't real you don't really don't
know what you're capable of yeah so that
was a really good good lesson for me and
um every day was a lesson like that one
of the things that seal said to me and
it's in in the book and one thing that
people have said that really resonated
with them he would say that when you're
when your mind is telling you you're
done you're really only 40 percent
done
and he had a motto if it doesn't suck we
don't do it and that was his way of
every day
forcing us to get uncomfortable to
figure out what our baseline was and and
what are you know
what our comfort level was and just you
know turning it upside down
the 40 rule maybe it's give or take a
little but look at a marathon most
people hit the wall at a marathon at
mile
anywhere from 16 to 20
and you know
99 of the people in this country that
run marathons finish
and they all predominantly all of them
go through this hit the wall so where
does that extra 50 or 60 percent or
whatever the number has come from i mean
it's their brain saying i'm done i don't
want to continue
but their will saying you know what let
me get to the finish line so we all have
that will
it's just a matter of how do we apply it
to
not just the once a year marathon but to
our daily lives and make it you know
apply to
a variety of things you know lisa when i
look back at all the things i've i've
done i've made so many mistakes but when
i look back at the things i've done
right it was always when i went with my
gut and and deciding to go into
journalism was one of them because um
like you mentioned in the intro i was i
went to graduate school at columbia and
everyone was getting these high-paying
jobs and you know you pay a lot of money
you know for school and then you have
this pressure um uh to get out and get a
job or to do something with it and the
average salary was 126 000 that year out
of columbia business school and i took a
job for 23 500 um because i went with
what i wanted to do in my gut what i was
passionate about which was you know
other people's stories and i i took a
job in the middle of washington state at
a small market but i learned how to
write and edit and and shoot and film
and everything and just put in the work
to try and build a foundation
the first three years of running this
business from my living room i couldn't
afford to pay myself and
literally hundreds of rejections i
thought ed oh i'm gonna shift culture
and beauty i have this great idea and
and you know so there's there's beauty
stores like sephora and ulta and qvc and
department stores every single one of
them said no
after no after no for three years
literally would say things like well
you're not the right fit
uh
your packaging isn't isn't prestige
enough and women won't buy makeup from
women they don't aspire to look like and
it was just no after no after no
um for three years uh we got down to
under a thousand dollars in our bank
account by the way i'm sharing this
because when you google my story and
this is why i wrote this book ed because
if we don't share the real stuff like
that's when we feel alone in our own
rejection and our own you know uh
lack of success or traction right and
when you google my story
all you ever see is like oh yes denny's
waitress sold her company for a billion
dollars cash and it makes it seem like
oh she just got lucky or bruised yeah
yeah and
you know it was a journey
that didn't make sense to keep going
except for every time i would check in
with my gut i was like okay i'm supposed
to do this
but everyone keeps saying no um you know
we got done under a thousand dollars in
our bank account as i mentioned and
sometimes when there's no proof around
you that your idea is right and like
your friends and family are starting to
worry about you
and they're starting to be like are you
sure you should have you know started
this are you getting any sales yet it
was like that and it was this this
three-year journey of having to figure
out how to turn down the volume
on my own self-doubt and
on rejection everywhere and kind of like
tune in or turn up the volume rather
than on that inner knowing that kept
telling me you're supposed to do this
um uh and that kind of was one of the
things that made all the difference i
kind of knew deep down inside like okay
i'm i'm created
for more in the sense of like i have
more to give and and more to create
um and more to serve and more to see
and i always kind of knew it um and i
went through this really life-long
journey though of like
like like knowing i i was kind of
created for more but doubting it anyway
and
kind of my whole life actually and maybe
a lot of people out there may be in the
same spot and it's kind of why i wrote
the book because i feel like
while it's my story of going from a girl
who didn't believe in herself to like
believing in herself and not not
trusting herself to learning actually
how to kind of like break through all
the self-doubt and hear that inner voice
and like and trust it um go from
doubting i'm enough to really on that
journey of knowing i'm enough the key
the the the key to i think being a good
um business leader is is your is how
good you are with people i think if you
can
care genuinely care about people um
not just your fellow directors but you
know the cleaning lady the switchboard
operator you know everybody throughout
the company
um you know if you're a good you know if
you know if you praise and don't
criticize um
uh you know people people will flourish
um and
uh so i think you know it it it's really
your people skills that will set you set
you apart
um
and
uh and uh and and i don't think that can
be over overemphasized i think um just
you just got to
um you know if i get if i'm on a virgin
plane i will make sure that i always
have a notebook in my back pocket
um you know make sure i get out and talk
to all the staff
you know if they've got issues you know
make sure i don't just you know hear the
issue and not write it down make sure
those issues get written down you know
talk to the passengers
uh if they've got issues make sure those
issues get written down i honestly just
don't think about mistakes but let me
see if i can chime in i i just like to
if i make a mistake i put it behind me
and i just move move move forward but
um
but
um
but uh
you know and and you know yes i've you
know i mean there have been you know
music musical bands that i've missed
trying to sign like dars straights um
uh you know there have been companies
that have fallen flat in their face like
virgin kohler
um
uh
you know but
uh uh
you know but
you know that's just part of that's just
part of um
uh you know being an entrepreneur you
you're gonna have these things happening
all the time so
i don't really see them as mistakes
they're just um you know they're just
uh
you know if you're an entrepreneur
you know that some things are not gonna
go right something isn't gonna go wrong
i was wondering how you define success
personally
well i
i can certainly define happiness because
that's what that's what i am i mean i i
and if that if that
i mean i get to do what i like to do
every single day of the year and i get
to do it with people i like
i get to i get
i don't have to associate with anybody
causes my stomach to churn
and
the only thing in my job i don't like
and this only happens about every three
or four years occasionally i have to
fire somebody and i don't like that's
the only thing other than i i tap dance
to work and i get down there and i think
i'm supposed to lie on my back and paint
the ceiling you know or something like
mine so i mean that's the way i feel and
and it it it doesn't diminish it it's
it's tremendous fun so
uh
you know if
uh they say that uh
success is uh
getting what you want and happiness is
wanting what you get well i don't know
which one
applies in this case but i
i do know that i i wouldn't be doing
anything else i mean
uh i do advise you you know and when you
go out to work go go to work for an
organization that you admire
people you admire because it'll it'll
turn you on and and
uh
you ought to be happy where you are
working and i always worry about people
who
say you know i'm going to do this for 10
years i really don't like it very well
and i'll do 10 more years of this i mean
that's a little like saving up sex for
your old age i mean
not a very good idea
so get right in recommend that get ready
get right in
get right into what you enjoy you know
and and
and you'll be successful at it you
really will i mean you won't be able to
miss and uh
um
you know that's uh
uh
i don't regard what i do as the most
important thing in the world at all but
it's right for me i mean i happen to be
wired in a certain way that what i do
works in this if i had to do
what
you know bill does i mean it lasts about
10 minutes and
that's true of a lot of things but i
luckily i kind of stumbled into the
thing that i i do best and and that you
know that it's worked out well how do
you turn failure into a plus
uh and it's true when i was at the
university of nebraska
one day i was reading the daily
nebraskan
and it said in room
300 or something
at three o'clock there will be this
panel of three
uh uh professors here at the university
and they're going to award the nathan
gold scholarship i don't know whether
you still you still have that room and
at the time
uh it said it would give you five
hundred dollars to go to the graduate
school of your choice i don't know
whether it's changed in the amount but
but that that was it so i read this
and i went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was
and i walked in the room
and there were the professors
and i was the only student that showed
up i mean it really got to them i mean
they they were stuck they you know they
kept waiting and looking at their watch
and hoping there'd be more candidates
but there no one came in so i won 500 by
by default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up
and so here i was i had 500
to go toward
any it wasn't it wasn't the limit as any
any graduate school for a master's
degree so i applied to harvard my dad
wanted me to
and uh
i shortly heard from harvard
and they said go to chicago and meet
this fellow running
that who interviews applicants from the
midwest
so i got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and i
spent about 10 hours on the burlington
going to chicago
then i transferred to another little
interurban train to go up to this
country day school where this fellow was
the headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for harvard
and i got there and after about
10 minutes he
he said
better think about something else that
uh you know he uh come back later on i
was i was 19 at the time and
uh
i looked about 12 you know and i and i
acted about eight it was not a great
combination uh but so he he said forget
it
so i spent that i took the little
interurban train back to chicago and i
took the 10-hour train back to oman all
the time i think you know what do i tell
my parents you know it's kind of
embarrassing
uh but
it was it was the luckiest thing ever
happened to me i
because
if i'd gone to harvard i would have gone
to a two-year
business school
i i instead applied to columbia where i
could graduate in one year and get a
master's degree
luckily
that by the accident of it and being in
the nebraska national guard which did
not get called up for the korean war
i missed
going in the korean war
i
i got to meet ben graham and which had
an enormous effect on me subsequently
and i probably got my wife that way
because she was going to northwestern
and i was able to put on sort of a full
court press because i got out in one
year and otherwise uh she'd she'd have
met some other guy i mean i i got her
before the competition showed up and
uh
so it worked out wonderfully it couldn't
have worked out better and
that's been that's been my life
basically i mean it the things
you know you will get some
disappointments you know
but
the future is what counts if i knew
every decision i was going to make was
going to be perfect it would not be as
much fun be like playing golf and
knowing you're going to hit a hole in
one on every hole you wouldn't play golf
if every time you got on a tee
you just took a swing and the ball ended
up in the hole you know be fun for a few
days you get on tv but it the game would
not be any fun uh so it's
failure you know
and i wouldn't even consider them
failures but they're mistakes or
whatever you want to call it they're
they're part of the game and
in the end you know you go on and and
we've made plenty of mistakes in
business we'll make plenty more
and then you know the
babe ruth and you know for a long time
it subsequently got eclipsed by
a few fellows but uh he held the record
for strikeouts you know he also the on
the record for home runs and was the
highest played baseball player until
the modern era came along so it's
it's part of the game if you take big
swings you know you
you may you may you're going to miss
sometimes what motivations do people
need to harness to try to make change as
opposed to just reading about change
um
and that's not supposed to be an easy
question
oh it's this
well
like i said i think if
if you study engineering and and you
figure out how to design new things
then
it's relatively easy to start a company
um
you just need to get a few like-minded
people
with you and then focus on creating a
prototype a compelling prototype as soon
as possible um and then
that you know there's a there's a strong
venture uh capital industry in this in
this country that will give you funding
to take things to the next level um and
that that's all there is to it um and
you might if you try it a few times you
might may or may not succeed but um i
think sometimes people fear fear
starting a company too much um you know
they have to say really what's worse
that could go wrong you're not going to
stop to death you're not going to die of
exposure um
what's worse i go wrong you are
unusually fearless and
willing to go in the face of other
people telling you something is crazy
and i know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out uh where does that
come from or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
um
so it's not as though
i just have the absence of fear i've i
feel quite strongly
but there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think i i i should
people should think well i feel fear
about this and therefore i shouldn't do
it um it's normal to be to feel fear
like you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong if you didn't feel fear
um
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually something
that can be helpful is fatalism uh to
some degree um if you just if you just
accept the probabilities um then
that diminishes fear
so
um when starting spacex i thought the
odds of success were less than 10
um
and i just accepted that actually
probably i would just lose lose
everything um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward
so that we still do some good
um yeah same with tesla i thought the
odds of a car company succeeding were
extremely low
we've got to try to create an electric
car company but it wasn't as though in
creating these companies that we thought
that we would be successful
i thought that the most likely outcome
was failure
but
but it was still worth doing even though
the the odds of success were low in fact
even for for support spacex
the
originally what i started doing was not
creating a rocket company but but
actually was going to do
a small mission to mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where you would
send a small greenhouse with seeds and
dehydrated gel in the wood
upon landing hydrate the gel and you'd
have
this cool picture of green plants on a
red background and the public tends to
respond to precedence and superlatives
so this will be the first life on mars
furthest that life's ever traveled
and you'd have this great money shot of
green plants on the red background
so
yeah i thought that would that would get
people's attention so
but the expectation for that was was no
return so i thought we wouldn't get any
uh you know we'll just spend the money
on that and it wouldn't wouldn't happen
it's all in the mindset
when you get up in the morning you do
what you normally do
i would eventually a lot of you here
probably turn on your cell phones your
computers and what's the latest email
what's the latest text that comes in you
start your day off like that
that's your mindset try this
get up in the morning do whatever you
have to do don't turn the computer on
don't turn the tv on go right back to
bed again either lay there or sit there
and just bring the universe to you
here's how you do it
you just be
it's virtually impossible when you first
do it because a thousand thoughts come
through your head we're human beings so
what you do is you're sitting in bed
look at the wall look at the off tv set
look at the ceiling look at the door
look at something in the room that gets
your attention
and just look at it and just be for a
couple minutes not 10 minutes not 20
minutes not two days just b when your
mind wanders find another spot in the
room to look at so you're back in
present time even for a couple of
minutes
now go about your day don't think about
what you're gonna do for that split few
minutes you're now becoming part of a
universe which is also part of global
thinking so of all the things in the
world that you could say are like the
secrets that being positive is one of
the
main things that people need to do how
did you happen on that in life
whether it's personal or people around
me when you see people that are positive
that look at something good and
something bad that took place
they move along in life faster they're
better
and people want to be around these
people i mean too often people gossip
the one gossip person wants to be around
the other person that gossips
but they don't realize
when you gossip you're saying something
you heard about somebody else you're
telling everybody what if part of it was
wrong you're gonna go out and tell every
person you told this oh i'm sorry it was
wrong tell everybody you told it's not
going to happen so it's things you learn
about don't gossip don't build little
people if you don't have to god please
don't try and look at the positive angle
what good could come out of something
and that positiveness is going to make
you live longer
happier and wake up in the morning happy
not oh my god i got to go to work i
can't wait till i get home i want to
retire
because people were not positive they
were not happy and what happens if they
retire they hate their job they retire
three or four years later they're dead
because they have nothing to do that
positive attitude be around positive
people encourage positiveness if you
find yourself walking around just
complaining all the time around people
that complain a lot man move or just try
and do something different change your
life
being positive and a positive attitude
is find something positive and something
bad
makes you look for solutions when i was
down and out okay oh pop bottles let's
get the pop bottles cash them in one of
the great secrets in life
to becoming successful
whether it's in a business whether it's
working with someone or for someone or
in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early 20s is be prepared in
life for a lot of rejection because if
you're prepared for a lot of rejection
it comes you don't get turned off you
don't get disappointed like well i'm not
going to do this anymore no one thinks
it's a good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars they slap
them in your face
you must be just as enthusiastic on door
number 101 as door number one and that's
what the real secrets and growing up as
kids in downtown l.a we all knew that we
didn't have a lot we noticed a lot of
things gonna turn you down at seven
trying to sell a flower pot on the
street most people said no but it's only
50 cents no no no
sooner a waitress a little restaurant
said only 50 cents that's really great
she bought it from us and we went and
built another one if you take a look at
life you can have your glasses they say
half empty or half full is how you look
at it now i've been homeless twice when
you are down
first time was 22 years old and i had a
child homeless with a kid you know he
was a couple years old which would be
interesting because most people see you
now in this multi-billion dollar
situation they would never believe that
at 22 you were homeless with a kid i
mean it didn't look like the trajectory
was heading here right yeah but when
you're down and out and you're that far
down and you've got a kid and you're
kicked out of your place because
rents do you don't have the money and
your wife took off with everything
everything yeah just little kids wow
anyways we were just too young to get
married uh so you know how to make it
now when you're that low
found a friend of mine who's a blue
singer said when you get down so low and
you look up all you could see is an edge
right when you're that low you could
only go up true so instead of you have a
choice you could sit around and blame
what happened to you on everybody else
which is usually what people do or say
hey that's how things turned out now i'm
going to turn things around you know
what's funny is i've never had a burnout
ever i've been and i've been i've been
going like this for for uh
a long time
decade 35 40 years even i mean i started
going at it in my teens hard and and uh
i never had that burnout and i think
that's kind of a state of mind that uh
if you you're going to get burnt out if
you want to get burnt out but but i
always was going like this and so i just
kind of felt like i'm so fortunate to to
to have it going why should i ever let
the momentum go the other way
and then of course you know one of my
great sayings is there's positive people
and negative people and and when you're
with a negative person or you're with a
positive person one of two things is
going to happen the negative person is
going to make the positive person
negative or you're going to take the
negative person and make them positive
so i've always paid attention to who
i've always been around also and and uh
i never wanted to be around people that
didn't want to achieve right and but
i've never even come close to saying i'm
done i'm burned out i'm not doing this
anymore and i always wanted to succeed
you know do i wish i wouldn't have
dropped out of college because i was
making money because i only had like 32
hours to go uh yeah but you know what
but now i'm the longest-running chairman
of the board of regents of that
university so it really doesn't matter
doesn't matter yeah exactly exactly so
but but but that bothered me for a long
time that i never finished school but
then as you become more and more
successful and you see all these other
guys in the forbes 400 too that never
finished school because because there's
something in us
that we just can't we can't have those
handcuffs on it we we're making money
and we i can't deal with going to class
i gotta i gotta make money and when i
was 21 years old i was already making
you know a couple hundred thousand a
year
that's big big money back and what this
is
in the early 80s wow that's big money
big money you know and people don't
realize that when you say i was making a
couple hundred thousand dollars but that
was big money huge big money when you
think about the fundamentals of a
business when you're going in to
evaluate a deal or whatever what like
key things do you look for well
everything is uh
occupancy cost uh term of lease do they
own any real estate
what are their margins uh i'm not real
smart but i know how to do that okay i
can analyze the numbers of any business
and tell you what your margin should be
or whatever because my production cost
is this i have this many subscribers you
should be doing this or that and i don't
care what the business is so that's what
i know how to do
and so
if i try to make the right deal and i do
heavy due diligence and and then
hopefully you can
continue to grow your net worth the
general theme i would suggest is that
all trends
are overrated
and so uh if you think about current uh
trends in technology uh you know uh
uh
healthcare i.t software education
software
overrated sas enterprise software really
overrated
big data cloud computing if you hear
those words you need to think fraud you
need to run away as fast as you possibly
can
and um and the reason these buzzwords
um
tell you that something um is that
there's these buzzwords they're sort of
like a tell in poker that people are
bluffing and that there's nothing that
there's uh that the business is not
undifferentiated because the buzzwords
tell you that it is one company of a
category that's undifferentiated from
the others in that category and
therefore
are symptomatic somehow of of um a lot
of competition and a bad a bad business
idea and so you know you don't want to
be the fourth online pet food company
you don't want to be the 10th thin film
solar panel company you don't want to be
the 1000th restaurant in san francisco
and so there is something about if you
can describe
what a company is doing
very straightforwardly by referencing
these these buzzwords these categories
that already exist
that's actually a sign that it's a
pretty bad uh that's that's a pretty bad
idea i think there's a problem in in
western europe where um where failure is
uh
it's it's too impossible to fail once
you fail you can never you can never
start over i think there's a there's an
opposite version of this in california
where i think sometimes people
are a little bit too facile about
failure because i i think it actually is
always incredibly damaging to people um
and if you work really hard at something
and it doesn't work um
uh that's you know that's that's going
to be psychologically damaging you know
people have less confidence you there
all sorts of reasons why why that tends
to be uh that tends to be quite bad i
think that um i think when people
i don't think there's that much you
learn from failure by the way because um
it's it's typically over determined it's
like why is technology slowing down why
did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you worked with the
wrong people the idea was bad the timing
was wrong it wasn't a monopoly the
product didn't work
and okay next time i'm working with
different people you figure out one out
of the five things you're likely to fail
fail again so i think i think failure is
not something one can learn very much
from i think that's sort of a myth that
i i would challenge
um but what i think what i think you
should do when you when when something
goes badly wrong is
you just keep going uh you you do
something else
and you don't dwell on the past i am
amazed at how few people have a belief
system what do they actually believe in
um
i
and and yeah it's okay to offend you
guys
90 of you will do what's expected of you
as opposed to what you want to do
and
you know i even when i come to an event
like this say why am i here why would i
even bother to take an hour of my
valuable time
no it's true i i have to have a purpose
my goal is very simple if i can convert
one of you
there's probably 400 500 people here if
i can convert one of you to follow your
belief and have the guts to follow your
belief
i'll have
i'll think of the hour as well spent
right
so i always say what am i trying to do
and why i don't speak because somebody
you know will write nice things about it
i always sort of have a purpose but i
have a belief system
and
most people even successful companies
and have big beef with fortune 500 ceos
i can talk about
there's very little leadership there
don't have an internal compass of what
they believe in
it's what do others expect
you know when i graduated i went into
entrepreneurship
nobody went into entrepreneurship out of
the business school and people said why
wouldn't you work
for goldman or mckinsey and i said why
would you
like i couldn't fathom why you would
want to
do that job
right
i still can't by the way
for those of you going to those places
and i'm sure there's plenty i'm probably
not the right person to talk to you
i frankly don't even care to talk to you
all of you others
i i think there's something wrong with
anybody who fundamentally wants to go
work for one of the consultants or the
investment banks today in this part
they don't understand how the world is
going to work in the future
but my point again is have a belief
system follow that compass
and i'm overstating it a bit so
there may be some hope for those of you
going there
uh but
it's only a little bit of an
exaggeration
let me go back to this issue of fortune
500 ceos
i've talked to many over the years
if a new york times writer writes an
article
they want to change their strategy they
want to respond
how silly is that that some english
major who's never had a business job can
determine the strategy of a fortune 500
company
why because they care about what's
written not what their belief system is
do you know what elon musk would say to
that writer go get a real job
right
what jeff bezos would say that's
leadership having a belief system
knowing what's driving you to do what
you do
not you fitting in to do career
enhancement
or
making it look good to somebody else
whether it's to your friends or to your
boss or to
shareholders
and frankly
you look at all the companies that are
languishing in the valley the older
companies
they generally don't have a belief
system they're generally trying to meet
some quarterly target without saying
here's how we will be different and
here's how we'll do it
apple did languish for 10 15 years and
then steve jobs came in with a point of
view and created the most valuable
company in the world he did irrational
things if you go back to january of 2007
january 1
everybody was saying nobody wants a
phone without a keyboard
nobody wants a phone that costs 6.99 i
can go on with the litany
those were all english majors writing
articles i have this beef against
english majors
not all english majors are bad but the
majority of them at stanford are
undirected and don't have a goal or a
purpose
sorry
and that's not to say among them there
isn't 20 percent that are really good
they just didn't get the right guidance
and ended up in the wrong place
i like purposeful education when one is
starting it's hard to say what whether
it'll be successful or not if it's an
assured success
then there would be no risk
if there was no risk everybody would do
it and if everybody was doing it it
wouldn't be unique or innovative so
innovation
fundamentally involves risk-taking and
risk-taking means failure
i like to say my willingness to fail is
what gives me the ability to succeed
and too many people just are not willing
to fail so they don't
try anything new
i like to say
you should try and fail
but not fail to try
because the people who fail to try fail
to take risk fail to do something
attempt something new
are failing before they start they just
don't know
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you
are awesome if you want seven more
amazing lessons from mega successful
entrepreneurs check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you're trying to convince the
public to do something you have to say
okay how's this going to read
and what message are we going to try to
convey
what will people respond to what would i
respond to